♂
あの僕昔SNOWの紹介したと思うんですよ
写真撮れるやつ
久しぶりに使ってみたらですね
結構いろいろ増えてまして
かわいい写真だけじゃなくて
こう、動物とか面白いやつとか
これだけなんかいろんなEffectあったら僕なんか
一人で全役できるんじゃないかと思って
ちょっと寸劇を作ってみました
ポチとの散歩です！どうぞ
おーい！ポチ
散歩行こうぜ！
ついて来いよ！
わーーん（遠吠え）おほおっほ！
ぐわっへぐわっへ！
いやーポチ！今日も天気がいいな！
へっへっへっへっへっへっへっへ
うわおーーーーーーーーーーんっふー
そうか～ポチも公園に行きたいか～
わしゃわしゃわしゃわしゃｗｗｗｗ
じゃ行こうぜ早速！
る～んるんるるんるんる～ん！
あー！はじめくんごきげんよ！
あ！セツコばあちゃん！
お久ぶりです！
あら！ポチは今日も元気だわねぇ~！
へっへっへっへっへっへっへっへ
ふゎぁ～～～（めんどい）
くっくっくっくっくっく
ッチ（舌打ち）(うっとうしいな！)
ポチ~！
ついたぞ～！
ふぉ~~~~~~~！
見てごらんポチ！
いろんな動物がいるよ！
ふゎぁ～～～～！ふゎぁ～～～～！
ドゥるるる！ドゥるるる！
くーーーん
ぶぶぶっふ（鳴き声）
恥ずかしい
ぷろーぷろー！
ぷろろーーーー！
ぴょんぴょんぴょんぴょん
あぁぁぁぁぁあぁぁぁぁぁ
あーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーー
ぐヴぁは！ぐヴぁは！
びヴぁゎーーーーーーーーー！
ぶーーーーーーーん
いぇーーーーーーーーーい！
おぼぼぼぼぼｂ
うーっふっふ
ヴぁ！
ヴぁ！っ
俺だわ
ヴぁ！
あ、俺だわ
ぶーぶーー（かわいい）
はんみゃかなはんにゃかなぶぶぶぶ
うぇー！
あーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーー
きゃーーーーーーーーー！（荒ぶるポチ）ぎゃーーーーーーーーーーーー！（荒ぶるはじめん）
いかがだったでしょうか
はい、というわけであの、寸劇どうこうというよりこれだけたくさんのエフェクトがあるっていうことを僕は伝えたかったでございます。
たとえばちょっとヒカキンさんに送ってみましょう
はい、そうするとヒカキンさんに　このまま今送りましたｗｗｗｗｗ
でゅてるて　でゅてるん　でゅてるて　でゅてるん　てーててててーてぇーてててーててててーてぇーててててーてぇーーむぺるぺむぺるぺぺーぺーぺーむぺるぺぺーぺーぺーふふふ
ｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗ